the Navajo Nation is experiencing one of
the highest coronavirus death rates in
the country surpassing 46 states the
massive reservation in the southwest is
home to more than a hundred and seventy
thousand people but around 30 percent do
not have running water think of that for
the CBS n original series Reverb
executive producer adam Yamaguchi shows
us how the lack of basic supplies makes
the virus harder to fight
now our do imagine how Navajo Nation has
been hit so hard considering that the
population is so sparse much of the
population
we've been on this terkoz for like an
hour functioning well let's hold that
the good chunk of the population here
they don't have water in the homes
they've got to come out here water some
of the most vulnerable residents aren't
able to make the drive to the near store
the matriarch of this family whose
grandmother experienced the years old
that's one of the things that they're
most afraid of is if they come and
become infected especially the ones that
go to dialysis stones are diabetic high
blood pressure those are the ones
because their immune systems are weak
like those I go to chemotherapy some of
these families are some of the
individuals the high-risk patients
they're asking for masks and they're
asking for gloves but we don't have
enough to go around and anima Gucci
joins us now from Los Angeles Adam good
morning you always have such beautiful
footage of what is often a grim
situation on the ground and that's
certainly the case here in the Navajo
Nation besides the lack of running water
what is it that makes them so vulnerable
to the corona virus well Native
Americans have the highest rates of
diabetes and hypertension in the entire
US and much of this is driven by lack of
access to health care but also lack of
access to affordable nutritious food in
an area that is the size of Vermont
Massachusetts and New Hampshire combined
they're only 13 grocery store
yet tons and tons of gas station fare
and fast food which by the way is a
common theme this we see across
communities of color that have been
disproportionately affected by COBIT
what Koba is revealed is a failure to
address some issues that have been
hiding in plain sight for a long time
and these communities are now seeing the
fallout from that you do so many of
these stories and I'm always interested
to know when you go into one of these
communities what you're expecting and
then what surprised you the most so in
this case what stood out you know I
think that in spite of the fact that the
situation is dire on the reservation
there are there are signs of hope you
know what we found time and again was
that the Navajo are incredibly strong
they're proud and they're resilient and
they're rallying together in ways that
they haven't seen in a long time young
people are reconnecting with elders and
getting in touch with the language and
culture that they may not have had much
closeness to in in in the past we also
saw farmers ordinary people taking up
farming for the very first time
rediscovering their ancestral plots of
land to try to take control of their
healthy food system so there is some
some positive to come out of what is a
pretty dire situation and hopefully that
that positive is reinforced now that
your report is drawing more attention to
the problems there Adam Yamaguchi thank
you very much and you at home can watch
Adams newest episode of the CBS n
original series of Reverb it's called
coronavirus in Navajo Nation and it is
streaming right now at CBS news.com
slash Navajo